for something
excuse me
welcome to the meeting members staff
counsellors
members of the public and the media
could you please remain outstanding for
the council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment as we face
the tasks before us
and enable us now and always worthily to
discharge the sacred trust
placed by the people
in our hands
amen
apologies
uh counselor rabbit your worship
thank you apology for uh leaving after
the 345
thank you okay
we should be on the off chance we're
still going to quarter past five i would
have to wait
i think okay
any more i've moved their apologies
being received and accepted secondly
thank you
put it for the vote all in favor say i i
it's carried
declarations of interest been no changes
there clearly none that i'm aware of
your worship thank you
uh public forum anyone speaking in that
none that i've
been requested
okay
move it that the minutes of the meeting
of council held on the 26th of october
2021 be confirmed
i happily moved those your worship
second both your worship
moved and seconded in discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye
aye is carried
um
you wish i'm sorry but it seems that
there is a major late item today
uh i'm not sure that it is
i thought it was amazing not on my
schedule
there's a um there is a
paper a
late item regional submissions on the
emissions reduction plan discussion
document
can i just check with the offices as to
whether any decision is required today
no no decision in which case it'll be a
minor late item
so we would ask that the council
consider whether it wishes to receive
the minor late item
the reason for it being late is a matter
of timing in terms of when we received
it and when we have to be in a position
to give feedback
i'm having a move that you receive
i think it's been moved and seconded any
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye thank you carrie thank you
here we go
to be moved to the minutes of the
infrastructural services committee held
on the 2nd of november
2021 be received i'll move that baby
received your worship
and recommendation to council
on the parking control yes and the
parking control by law
discussion questions
thank you
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
aye
it's carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
risk and assurance committee held on the
3rd of november
happy to move towards your worship
second
moved and seconded discussion questions
put it to the vote
the minister performance policy and
partnerships committee
bishop i thought there's an emergency
meeting
oh sorry
moved at the minutes of the
emergency meeting of council out on the
5th of november 2021
i'll move that your worship i'll second
it your worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
it's carried
the minutes of the performance policy
and partnerships committee out on the
9th of november
pleasure
thank you
thank you
second
and can i just ask with the mover and
second are intended the recommendation
to count
thank you
so we haven't put
that one you can pop that now the
worship performance report for the three
months to the 30th of september
it's been moved and seconded by
councillor ludlow and councillors
councillor ludlow and lewis councillor
lewis thank you
uh seconding that
move here
i'll put it to the vote all in favor say
aye
carried
and bring him in to council
that had approved the following budget
forecast changes
3.476 million budgeted for the
demolition of the esk street
west
buildings is no longer required
with the sale of those properties
the funding for the demolition is
transferred to
capital contingency yes worship that was
part of the original motion
thank you a second for that
it's been second of your worship
the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of the risk and assurance
committee
i'll move those minutes
second did your worship
held on the 15th of november 2021
you received
um your worship i'm stopping and
hesitating because i am aware that the
risk and assurance committee discussed
the matter of the transition plan for
external appointees
and there is a separate agenda item on
the same matter which i believe is to be
withdrawn
so there's been a double up and you
don't need the separate item
um headed transition plan for elected
members on that basis i was just looking
and wondering whether mrs parker had
anything she wanted to add to this
report
um
for the record counsellors the
report that clears talking about item 11
should in fact be withdrawn because it's
covered in the risk of insurance
and minutes
the resolutions are exactly the same and
just for clarity
there were minor changes in the report
to cancel
there's a
spelling error on page
36 i probably don't need to go into that
in detail the
words
that make it very clear that the
like your ears i'm just going to read
this it's just gone from my screen
[Music]
the words
the
the ea's supporting mentoring and
process focused role
um will continue through to at least
march 22 review but no later than the
30th of june that was simply for clarity
and the final change was that appendix e
the chairs terms of reference were
updated to reflect what what is in fact
in the report
these were very minor changes
and as claire says
it is appropriate to withdraw this
report because it's a double up
thank you so that's a big move as an
amendment no your worship i wanted
be
councillors
of this in case they wanted to have a
discussion on the item and they felt
that the next report would be
coming forward it won't be coming
forward we'll withdraw that
and
this i don't think it's been moved yet
um
right okay so it's been moved and
seconded and it's got the
recommendations to council in it it's
these recommendations here i know your
worship let's change over
uh no
it's here the minutes of the
extraordinary it's um there's
this series of recommendations here
and i'm gonna mark with 10.
um
i'm sorry counselors worship has a
um there's some sensitivities in the
agenda and so he has this has been taken
out in by mistakes so this is the matter
on the transition plan for external
appointees you'll see it all on the on
the screen
thank you
so it's been moved and seconded
so
i think councillor pottinger has a
question
i'm still a partner thinking your
worship um look can i just get some
clarity
on point three of item eleven
uh the establishment of a new group
supporting the mayor
i wasn't at the risk insurance meeting
i'm just wondering what the context of
this is
there i've got that as item four yeah
so and in the
report
on 10 is actually item four
confirms the support for the supporting
meters group so this came from uh can i
speak your worship
sorry do you want to deal with the
minutes of risk insurance first or do
you think that
could do yes we've got confused by
putting the same item on
in a number of different places and i
apologize it's not been helpful
um
do the moments first do do the minute so
that is worship
so just receiving a minute
receiving
so i had it it was a question from
councillor pottinger wanting to know
about
item 10 4. your worship i think i think
the intention
of council is if we could just vote on
accepting the minutes of the
extraordinary risk then we can pick up
that question in the next item
you agree with that i think it would be
helpful you worship yes if you can
receive the minutes and the
recommendations i think that would be
helpful
they've been moved and seconded your
worship so you just need to put them
thank you for that
i'll put that to the vote all in favor
say aye
against carrick
so your worship
mr grant will now speak to ipt
thank you thank you worship so just um
picking up this is a report from pgg
uh which then went to the riskin
assurance which
uh sets out a range of recommendations
which you'll see in the full extent in
terms of the rna report i just note that
um
in terms of these recommendations the
project
is still well on budget in
both the last financial year and the
proposed financial years we're going
into and the recommendations are
predominantly around the transition plan
for the eas
i'd also note that the department of
internal affairs and the commentary
to the project governance group said
that they felt there had been a maturing
in terms of the work done by both
council and staff
and that the transition was a probably
an appropriate time the recommendations
take effect on the first of december
they include um that the deputy mayor
take over the role as chair of pgg and i
would step down as one of the eas
the two deputies
on the cheers group would
take on the role of joint chairs of the
cheers group
that was predominantly expressed as a
preference by the pgg on the basis of
sharing the workload amongst those on
the chairs group
and that also the eas would
back off in terms of their involvement
and only one of us would attend both
committees and council each week
as appropriate and as the question
raised by councillor pottinger there was
also a recommendation uh to continue
support for the mayor
which was part of the ce
and mia's
working group
so on the basis that the rest of the
working groups were to be collapsed and
that there was a discussion at pgg
on the view that there may be a good
argument to continue some support for
the mayor
uh around
the issue of both well-being and also
for matters that may
come to the attention of the council by
the mayor in regard to services
so that is for an open discussion for
the council to decide but they were the
basis of recommendations in the report
thank you angela parringer i'm just
asking the question what
what is what does supporting them mean
or what what roles are we talking about
and
um i'm just a bit i just like a bit more
detail if possible
look i
think i could reflect worship
the discussion pgg was just the general
principle support for the mayor and with
the involvement
of an informal group of councillors
if there was the need to
have a more defined role then that
should be something the council should
ask for
the
pgg to look at
the reason i ask this is that if we
leave it too open then it's it is open
to
misinterpretation i think we need to be
more prescriptive if possible if such a
group was to exist
counseling thank you worship um yes i'm
about to be chair of the tgg group um
so i guess i've got some issues with uh
recommendation four in in tab ten and
also the uh the last statement in the
summary that says that this supporting
the mayor's group should go forward
i've been involved with the group from
day one the supporting the mayor's group
um it was actually as rightly reflected
supporting the mayor and chief executive
and we've made the gains that we want
with the chief executive support and so
that's now refocused on the mayor
i've asked today the mayor i've asked
amir today whether he wants that group
to continue
and he said he did but i will be seeking
some advice from him today about what he
sees are the outcomes of that group
would want to achieve
and that's what councilor pottinger is
raising as well because i don't want us
to have a group for the sake of having a
group
it's got to have some tangible outcomes
and given that the mayor has pushed back
on the thompson report and most of the
outcomes contained within it i want to
make sure that we're getting something
out of this
because this will involve councillors
putting in time
the other issue is that we've had i
guess a range of
issues that have been thrown up by the
mayor
certainly in the media recently in
relation to
clerical support pa support uh cell
phones
bottled water and other things
and and while there are physical things
there is some need potentially to
support the mayor with his well-being as
well so he feels okay about coming into
the
uh into the business
and so that that wording was slightly
changed at the last pug meeting to
reflect that but i
my understanding from the mirror is he's
uncomfortable with the words well-being
as well so would seek some clarification
on that because going forward we need to
know where we stand
any further questions or issues
our
to continue
and also to tell
elected members um who are going to be
elected to this group because we are
looking for some new new bodies on them
on on the committee
on the group um
what outcomes are what what you see as
being the benefit for you or for the
organization if we keep this group going
because my initial view is i think we
should lapse the group now
so if you could help us with that that
would be great
yes any further issues
um
it's a very difficult
job to just just
to organize and to spell out the people
what it's about
um
the
i think the
pressure's on of course because
when i first began it became there we
just having a statement
and now we've got computers
and
it's uh
it's it can be a challenge
for some of the senior citizens and it
can also be a liberating force but
in this case
um
i think
it's
we get guidance on the role of the mayor
through
publications that come out
and they state quite categorically that
amir is not doing a nine to five job
it's
i think um
a challenging role it would be very hard
to find a description that would suit
all 78 mayors and chairs in this country
but um
it's also
it
gives an opportunity to
take aboard
some real
success stories and some
uh
gigantic disasters
and it's um
the success stories for me are
i worked out that housing was the most
serious
um challenge for
the city
and so i set about
buying a house of bluff
and
buying another one
for
the dan daven house
and spent a lot of time and energy
repairing them and
um
contributing to
draw attention
to the
problems we faced in that area
i also think the next most important job
for me anyway
was promoting the city we were the
fastest declining city in new zealand or
australia
and i just felt
uh we needed to change our image
so i got involved in movie making with
the world's fastest indian
and
sit who had a big housing
for stu or
apartments for students
and
a zero fee scheme of course it was also
successful
um
and
i don't expect counsellors will agree
they see
often
the most important thing is attending
meetings and
and they judge you by that
activity
but i'd like to get
involved
and
so i think this committee should
continue but i'd like to see it changed
at the moment it's
linked to a 12-hour
basis
and after 12 hours just in the last two
days
and
so i think and i think the committee
would agree that
the um
the
i don't have that answers in question um
sorry worship it was more like a beehive
press release but
um
i i think what i'm asking for is what
are the roles of the councillors because
there will be council is volunteering
for this committee
and
and and sort of the details i was after
is it is it attending zoom meetings on
your behalf is it attending
functions is it is it things like that
more specific that you don't have the
time for or whatever that's what i'm
trying
to get an answer for
what aspects
of support
you know
those those things i'm just because if
you know as council clark said there
will be
um obviously uh councillors wanting
to enlist for this job and i i
imagine they would like to know what
they're up for
the short answer is i don't know
the
although meetings are
set out quite clearly usually
[Music]
it's
it's things just come out of nowhere
and
i'm just
come from shooting a
an advert for
the house board
to get people vaccinating
and
those are the sort of things that
you don't prepare for or you don't know
about until they actually
happen
so i can understand your frustration
so so given that answer i would actually
like to move that that item be withdrawn
from on that list
to support group
not be established
sorry
the answer does not give me confidence
that it's worthwhile
setting up
can they put a major um resolution at
the stage i think councillor pottinger
is moving an amendment that that item be
deleted that that paragraph four
um
be deleted would be the easiest way for
that to be handled procedurally
it's moved and seconded that item four
be deleted
sorry it's it equates to an amendment
an amendment
now of course after that
talk i
trying to explain what we're doing
or what amir does
i think the only real
answer to that is
looking at
election results
it's the ultimate test
of whether you've been a successful
mayor or
not quite such a successful man
counselor
ludlow you your worship um
so i'm speaking against the amendment
uh and and
think that
putting the facility to have the
committee to provide
support
in whatever form is needed
um
would be a good proactive step
um
however i do take on board the comments
from both councillor pottinger and
councillor clark that some detail around
it would be
useful um i i don't know that we're
going to come up with those today but
maybe that's
something that can be thrashed out over
the next couple of weeks before the the
committee
uh
starts i mean they've got to have a
purpose
and and i think it's a good opportunity
to
define down
what that purpose
is and and what is needed that fits
within the realms of of what we're able
to do um
if
if his worship is spending
all day in meetings
um that that doesn't actually require
office support
but if
for all the other things that that go on
as a part of the role
making sure that we've got adequate
support in place is as is one of your
concerns then
we probably need to to thrash that out a
little further so personally i'd like to
see it stay in
discussion questions
and select that
so just going back on to some of the
issues that i initially spoke to
and i just want to quickly run through
so the public are aware of what we're
doing and why we're doing it
and we set out
after the thompson report to
um put in place some pa or clerical
support whatever you want to call it it
was deemed at the time that 12 hours a
week would be okay and the chief
executive had a caveat to that that
allowed for additional
hours to be put in on a needed basis
um that hasn't occurred so that would
signal to me that the mayor has adequate
hours attached
and while his worship refers to doing 12
hours in the last two days
his pa doesn't need to attend to those
pa predominantly manages the office
and potentially could do some
some research on his behalf if he was
going to a meeting so the issues that
we've dealt with initially with the
group are the pa's role which i think
has resolved the cell phone which has
been dragged up recently
has been offered on more than one
occasion and has been declined by the
mayor and his partner
i treat it training's been offered up on
at least three occasions and accepted
once and declined on the other two
occasions
and we've had allegations of bullying
which have been resolved at the mayor's
suggestion that we take it no further he
was offered to have an independent
investigation of that so the physical
things around the job that have been
raised is
as an organization we haven't responded
to to that and not true we've worked our
way through each and every one of those
issues including the stored items that
have been across several venues and
we're just about to the end of that as
well
so i support the fact that i don't see
any benefit for this group going forward
um the mayor told me he's resistant to
the well-being angle that i initially
was in support of because i thought we
might have been able to help him on the
well-being
area but he's not interested in that
he's purely focused on the other issues
so
just to reinforce that i
i support the amendment
further discussion questions
answer the server
thank you your worship um
i'm going to speak on this one because i
don't support the amendment i think the
sorry
[Music]
i'm going to speak on this one because i
don't support the amendment i think that
there is some worth in um leaving this
recommendation in and as councillor
ludlow suggested having some more
conversation to flesh out the
requirement outside this meeting we are
not going to progress fleshing out the
material today i'm looking at page 34 of
the agenda
where bullet point 2 says the group
should comprise an informal team of up
to five councils who would look for
opportunities to engage with the mayor
consistent with the group's purpose and
report to the pgg
that seems to me like it's worth having
more conversation about how that's
fleshed out so i would be reluctant to
just see the initiative removed in the
spirit of the thompson report i'd like
to see it stay in place
in the conversation about exactly how
that's going to be put in place develop
some
more
thank you
thank you councillors any further
discussion
to the vote show of hands please
all in favor of the amendment say aye
against
in which case you go back to the
substantive motion you worship which is
all four paragraphs
and you
may like to see if there's any questions
or whether you wish to just put that now
i think we've had enough discussion oh
no sorry on on page um page 34 as uh
councillor saper quite rightly
recommends um there is a suggestion that
um
the group that goes forward which we've
now
approved
has up to five councils and it would be
helpful from a pgg perspective if we
could identify whether there are people
within our elected members group who
would like to be on that
group um i'm currently on it but i will
withdraw because
um my relationship with me is uh
strained and so um i think it would be
lindsay abbott already cheers her group
so there's one but i just want to know
from my colleagues where there are other
people that would like to be on that
group
any volunteers
oh
very good there you go i'm just getting
there you wish i might just say i quite
like the the word on page 34 the first
paragraph uh engaged the mayor
is an informal team of up to five
councils so it's not a strict
it's not a strict um
documented program an informal one is it
leaves a little bit open that would be
often you would arrive if you're
at
the
meeting and your transports held up it
could be
perhaps escorting you to the rugby or
something of that nature i assume i'm
not too sure exactly what the informal
thing
uh involves but i would be quite happy
to put my hand up as i just indicated
thank you
i'll put it to the vote all in favor say
i
like against
carried
where are we up to
transition plan
no that's the item that's been withdrawn
your worship so the proposed replacement
of media protocols
thank you
it's another tricky subject for dealing
with the
media um
and it's had a rocky
road
as a result
um
so mr knight has come to speak the
report okay
welcome to the meeting
thank you your worship
i'll just pull that close enough lisa
that jane can hear you jane and lindsay
um
as you know the media protocols were
introduced in february of this year in
response to richard thompson's
recommendations in his initial report
last year
they were intended as a support and a
guide for councillors and their
interactions with media
i think it's fair to say
the intention and the perception did not
align
and given that interpretation richard
thompson made some further
recommendations in his six-month review
to reconsider the media protocols
the
report and the recommendations that you
have in front of you here today are a
result of the working group having
considered again the intent of the media
protocols
and how we would suggest moving forward
and i'm happy to answer any questions
so
thank you worship
um look my question is just regarding i
guess the charter which involves the
media protocols and how it
all combines with our existing
code of conduct which has its own
section on
media protocols
and values are they going to be
incorporated into one document on our
governance
section of their website or
rather than have two sets of road rules
we're going to i mean you don't want to
be
dancing between
70k and 80k or mr chair
i might ask councillor pottinger if
you'd like me to answer that question
because ms knight is the comms manager
not the governance manager right
and would be unfamiliar with that
document in the first instance
the count the governance statement or
the government's
statement and suite of documents
is in response to the legislative
requirements the charter was developed
afterwards and to date has not been
included
or appended to that suite of documents
so it sits outside of it
that's something whether you wish to
include that in the
governance statement after the next
training would be an opportunity for the
incoming council
the reason i'm very cautious about this
is that in in the introduction to the
code of conduct it has a set of eight
values now these values
even though
they sort of align with the charter
don't exactly align with the chart
and the same with the media protocols
even though they sort of align
they don't exactly align so you could
choose
depending on what you're doing
to say well i'm just i'm just obeying
the
code of conduct or
yeah i'm just
hoping that we can get some cohesion
mr chia um
or your worship or correctly i apologize
uh your worship
uh the intention of this is to draw the
counsellor's attention
in whatever language works for them
the need to have a code of behaviour
that everyone is comfortable with
the charter was developed after the
thompson review and developed with the
input of everyone
sitting at the table
and
that is the primary document i think in
terms of the first port of call
if you and i also believe that mr
thompson has identified that
a well-functioning council sorts out its
differences between itself
rather than filing code of conduct
complaints
so the issues that your raising council
councillor partinger i think on a strict
interpretation you're absolutely correct
i think on a given little interpretation
we would say on the 23rd of november
let's work with those two guiding
documents as a way to make sure that our
behaviour fits within one of those at
the very least and you draw a really
good point about the attention that we
should give to
marrying the values and the behaviors in
the next governance statement
right so that won't um currently that
charter when you go to the website
doesn't sit there you how does someone
find it so your worship if we don't have
it on the website already we will make
sure it is on the website
and we will put it under governance and
we will put it in the same section
uh we might put it more than once
but
it won't be embedded in the statement as
that needs to come back to council
and in its most simplistic form i'd
suggest to you that you've got better
ways to spend your time then and the
office's time then reviewing that
document at the stage of the training
thank you any further discussion
questions councillor edmondson
thanks as the chair of the
working group for media protocols
just like to add that what we found when
we went back and reflected on these
media protocols after this six monthly
review from richard thompson was
actually that we almost jumped the gun i
guess in terms of developing media
protocols to solve the problem of how we
managed counsellor behaviour in elected
member behaviour and what we realized is
that the charter which we had been
working on at the time but wasn't
completed until april actually was the
thing that should provide the guidance
for us on how to
deal with behaviour in the first
instance and where
that had done its work and more action
was necessary then we would step to the
code of conduct
to to finish the job so to speak
so that is the reason why we have come
forward with these recommendations
which does include that the charter
supersedes the media protocols and as a
result we should
revoke the media protocols and the
reality is i guess the media protocols
also only
sort of touched on things that were
already mentioned in the code of conduct
anyway by way of reminder to councillors
but as has been mentioned um by the
officer you know that was not the
perception um or the um
the feeling that the community uh got
from them so i'm quite happy to move all
of those uh recommendations
i'm quite happy to second those
recommendations your worship
moved and seconded it
question oh counsellor
ah no you worship it's been said
to do the discussion on
media protocols
yes
thank you worship
i've always been in favor of
free speech
uh we've got to let the citizens know
what we're thinking about
and we should bring it out into the open
even even if it's uh criticizing fellow
councillors or even you you worship
i've been a bit baffled by this
a meeting i missed
various reasons a few weeks ago
councillor pottinger
made comment about the labour government
and minister mahuta regarding the three
waters
and i felt it was a straightforward and
honest comment
and good honor for that
but then
councillor soper bailed him up and
accused him of grandstanding
i don't know it was any grandstanding
that he spoke his open mind
and as i said good on him for that
so
free speech yeah bring it on okay
it's going to be a very interesting ten
and a half months and
i'll be speaking my mind thank you very
much
thank you now councillor thank you
worship i'll roll out my favorite saying
freedom of speech exists but it is not
freedom from consequence
thank
you okay
anything
house counselors registered
oh let's go to the club uh yes your
worship um
reading through the media protocols it
seems to me that
we have a set of standards through
several documents on what our behaviour
should be around the media
one of the key thing that's on page 49
is the need to discuss
the issues and to debate the issues but
not to this
but not to use that venue
or that opportunity to criticize
unfairly uh another person
so you don't play the player you play
the ball as it were
and so
casting my mind back in the last six
months i don't know how this will
resolve behaviour that's
not adhering to that playing the ball
issue
it's well documented that i've had some
public criticism from the mayor and some
name calling from the mayor and the
media and i've elected to do nothing
about it because i just i just think
that probably will judge him for that
but it seems to me under this protocol
now
that where we have behavior that we
don't think it's right
that that behave should initially go to
the chairs group a group that the mayor
says is an inappropriate group and is
splitting our council in half
and then as a second option if the
chairs can't resolve it it goes to a
code of conduct
now i don't want us to have a whole
series of conduct
complaints that they achieve nothing
they're like wet bus tickets
they cost us a lot of money
and and they ruin our reputation in the
community but there must be some better
mechanism for us to hold each other
accountable for our behaviour than just
going to the cheers group and i'm still
lost on what that should be
thank you further questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say hi
move on to the proposed revision of the
built-in
there were actions identified within the
city center heritage strategy and one of
them was to create incentives to support
heritage resources while the initial
focus of those incentives was towards
the 25 buildings and streetscapes
identified within the strategy
the city central heritage steering group
looking at it two years in sees an
opportunity to broaden those incentives
to a larger audience
as such they propose to revise this
year's build heritage fund and dedicate
a portion of the funding towards owners
of all recognized heritage buildings
located within the city center heritage
area
specifically for facade enhancement
works it means that all the owners that
were originally included within the
strategy they can apply for a wider
variety of works so this is solely for
the facade enhancement portion
the revision stems from the level of
redevelopment currently taking place in
our city center which we're all well
aware of as well as the low funding
uplift
from owners within the first two funding
rounds and that's mainly due to several
external factors
the revision seeks to further support
heritage building owners and to
encourage enhancement of our city
streetscapes
the report recommends that
council receives the report and endorses
the proposal to revise the built
heritage fund
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you questions counselors
answer the client yes um we've had a
discussion already about this
but it seems to me that we're
we're cherry-picking a little bit about
the buildings that we want to invest
some upgrade in
um based on available funding and it
seems sad to me that we're putting
i don't know this
this council is putting probably
somewhere north of 60 million dollars
into a into a city block project and
streetscape i think maybe more than that
um
and yet we're not prepared to put money
into
upgrading the facades of some of the
streets that are joining there so um and
i appreciate that we're doing it from
the perspective of the heritage fund but
it's a bit of a sad indictment that
there will be other buildings that will
sit there and and what appears to be a
pretty horrible state so i know you've
identified about
about two dozen buildings but there's
about 40 i think from my memory or 42
that need some work
so i guess the challenge for us is just
to try and find out
um how we can help the owners of the
other buildings
who aren't heritage but they're still
very old buildings so that our inner
city starts to look much sharper than it
should than it is at the moment
and i know we've had previous debate
about that and we got roadblocks
and saying that we couldn't put
ratepayers money into a private building
um but it's it's more than that it's
actually the face of our new city which
we're trying to create
so
just wanted to
acknowledge that what the work you're
doing here is great
but it's a challenge for us to try and
do further work because it's no good
just doing heritage buildings
if every third building gets an upgrade
and the others beside them look pretty
ugly it
it's like having a neighbour's property
right next to you very expensive homes
got long grass it just
doesn't do what we're trying to do
okay just a challenge in that area
don't tell it crack it oh thank you you
worship um
i do get councillor clark's point um
and that
really
quite a lot of the city and if you do a
walk around and you have a look above
the facades um
quite a lot of them are in a state of
neglect
or so not so much but
in some cases quite severe disrepair um
we do have an environment um
applications that actually allow us to
control those sorts of things and you
know request that the building owners do
keep the upkeep in that but it only goes
so far
um i think with this being able to pivot
and repurpose this funding for this
purpose for heritage building
specifically actually brings in a level
of equality for all building owners
because i mean if you've got heritage
building the remedial action is
typically a lot more expensive to outlay
for
special you know this special treatment
special plaster it's special
heritage items or that you that you're
trying to restore
so
this actually does go away to you know
provide a fund so that others those
in the heritage listing can
afford to upkeep their buildings or
afford to bring them back up to standard
uh and more in line with those that own
commercial buildings that aren't
protected by those heritage
restraints do
thank you
thank you
counselor
thanks um
i'm part of the heritage steering group
and we were really excited when we
realized that there was an opportunity
here for us to be able to provide some
extra support and funding for
some wider heritage building owners in
our cbd
unfortunately for us it is a heritage
fund and so that is why the funding is
targeted at heritage buildings but
certainly acknowledge that there are
some other buildings that could probably
do with a wee bit of support or help as
well and maybe the council can
consider that and how we might do that
in another way
um would really like to thank shannon
personally for all of the great work she
has done with the heritage building
owners she is one of the reasons why the
ones who are in the strategy
have got a bit of a backload of work
because she has helped them to get
heritage equipped funding
and also to take up the other funding
that we have um had on offer as a
council that they haven't quite been
able to use yet
so her and also to liz who i know gives
her a lot of help in that area
so i'm quite happy to move those two
recommendations
thanks
thank you
second
your worship and i'm also a member of
the committee and endorse what
councillor munson has said on this
matter it is a filthy heritage fund
so council wishes to have a conversation
about a
fund that is
a a built fund
without the heritage word that would
expand the support that would be a
conversation for another day
i wish i would
put my hand down but i would like to say
something i also would endorse it and i
would make sure people realize it's not
a total cost of any renovations it's
it's incentive to help help the other
the building owners get involved
and they appreciate it very much and i
also
endorse the hard work that shannon
anders do on this committee thank you
very much as i am a member of that
committee
thank you thank you
councillor ludlow
thank you your worship um
i'm not a great fan of
ratepayer money
doing the general maintenance that
uh
a building owner is expected to do as
part of their investment
i mean they're happy enough to charge
rent for it maybe they need to look
closely at the rentals that they charge
but i also recognize
that in the case of heritage buildings
there's a greater hurdle
that those building owners have to
overcome financially and we want to try
to encourage
the retention of of those features in
our in our streetscape
but counselor clark makes a a good point
in the
recognition
at least if not subsidizing because i'm
not a fan of that
but recognition of the work
that some building owners have done that
that aren't in heritage buildings is a
really valuable thing we used to
uh have an awards function each year
where we recognized those building
owners
within the the cbd who who had invested
in their buildings and and upgraded them
and presented them with plaques which i
saw proudly displayed in businesses all
over town and
and they were valued and i think it's
probably worth us looking to
to perhaps reignite those you know for
the for the cost of
of of half a dozen or a dozen plaques
and and
a supper after a presentation um it's a
really good investment for what
these businesses have put into the
building and hopefully it can be seen as
another way of encouraging those who
don't have the heritage buildings to to
take that next step
thank you councillor
thank you worship the guy
i really want to
carry on strongly with what counselor
clark said because
it makes
total sense in the fact that if you are
funding
the refurbishment or at least painting
you are control
of the color scheme the coordination
to make it look right if we leave it up
to individuals to do whatever they want
to they may want to paint their front
purple just to be the standout shop but
at least if we
are the funder
we have the ability
to be control
of what we want it to look like and i
think that's critical we're spending 22
million
on don and history
i really think everything else has to
surrounding it needs to come up to shape
and i i think you know if you go to
places that have been done
professionally the street fundages
complement each other color schemes do
there's a lot more to it than just
plaster and doing things up this is
we're talking about something that works
so i actually support councillor clark's
idea and that council should
with its streetscape
focus
look at funding towards supporting other
buildings
thank you
worship i think uh council potential
sentiment it's fantastic but i would
just ask liz perhaps what control we
have over the color schemes with the
heritage buildings i think we have
control don't we but they're general
public builders we don't have to control
yeah and i think that that's what
counselor ledlo was a alluding or sorry
counselor pottinger was alluding to that
with heritage there's a approved icc
heritage color palette but obviously it
only extends to heritage buildings um
we're always
i still have contact with a lot of the
non-heritage owners through a lot of our
seismic strengthening work as well um
and we always say that they're welcome
to chat with us but at the end of the
day it's their building and they can
decide to do what they want in terms of
color thank you
councillor cricket thank you worship um
might i suggest as uh chair of
infrastructure that um
councillor pottinger request a paper or
investigation on perhaps
some sort of
uh support for building owners in the
inner city as we roll forward into the
next tier of streetscapes
have i got a support group
[Laughter]
what it
i thank you for your worship yeah i just
want to endorse council clark council
pottinger an excellent idea from
councillor cracker i think that's
overdue
i think it'd be a really positive sign
that we've been sending to the wider
community as well there's many other
things that we've invested in and once
again
we can have we've got another
opportunity to do so so we've got one
shot at this so we i look forward to
seeing a paper
with some costings around it
yes just to add to what i said before um
i get feedback from landlords that say
that over a period of time the city has
drifted away from where it currently is
the cbd
and particular across to where the
warehouses and other places down there
and so they've lost tenants in that
process so if you go look at a lot of
these buildings that we're talking about
not the heritage ones but the other ones
that are in this immediate block that
we're trying to
enliven
they have ground floor tenants but they
have nothing above
um and so they don't have a lot of uh
rental power to go doing up buildings
and no incentive to do so
my assessment was uh when i initially
had a look at the
42 buildings putting aside a couple of
brands that need to be done
i thought that um the water blasting of
those buildings and some initial
painting and heritage type colours which
would be great for our cbd was probably
about 6 thousand six to seven thousand
six to seven hundred thousand dollars
worth of work
over a period a few months in summer and
that sounds an awful lot of rate past
money but when you consider our
streetscapes as somewhere around 25
million dollars plus for two and a half
streets it's a small investment to
really get this right
so um expecting landlords without some
help to do it some of them just won't
cope with that and that will devalue
what we're trying to do
thank you
thank you
councillor edmondson
another suggestion might be inviting icl
to
consider contributing to something to do
with the buildings that aren't heritage
buildings
i noticed that uh scott has already
offered to help out nest street on the
north side of the street
but our cbd is bigger than that
thank you your worship um with the
suggestion from councillor crackit and
the further suggestion from councillor
munson it seems to me that we've got
some very meaty issues to arrive in a
report and we're probably not going to
get a lot further speculating about
possible costs or whatever
at the table without a report
so perhaps it's a good
a good place at which to draw the
conversation to a close and look forward
to some report
all right since you had your hand up
counselor thank you just just to extend
on that your worship um i know this
council has talked about not only the
street frontages but the and councillor
clark has just referenced it and the
fact that there's rental uh retail on
the bottom quite often or commercial
entity on the bottom for renting but
nothing on the top and a lot of that is
around what the building owner can
actually purposefully use the building
for
so i wonder if there would be appetite
for this council to extend that report
and potentially have a look at
uh what constraints they have on whether
or not what they can use those buildings
for whether or not it's residential
living in a city sorry residential
living because we've talked about that
as something that could be remedial for
getting those buildings in the inner
city up and running and humming and
being used
um
so i know we've talked a lot about what
levers we can pull to change that to get
a lot more foot traffic in the city and
this report could be um
wider than that and treat that issue as
well
or at least investigate it
thank you
you're just receiving that family
you worship the recommendations are in
front of you that you receive it and
that you endorse
the change to the built heritage fund
thank you
the council received the report of 2022
meeting schedule no sorry you worship
we're at faith
um
revisions
the council receives the report titled
proposed revision of the
2021-2022
build
heritage fund
that council endorses the
proposed provision to the 2021-2022
build heritage fund
put it to the
right
against carriage
thank you
thank you
do we need to formalize the request for
that
um
your worship counselor crack it's asking
about a report
for a further item that report would be
a matter for a committee in the first
instance
as it would
this has come forward to this commit to
council on the basis that it's a change
to the
terms of reference for the city centre
steering group
but to consider the matter further would
be a committee item i think if the chair
of ppp was to
[Music]
acknowledge that that's where it would
sit
and to take
um
infrastructure
infrastructure infrastructure perhaps
i heard it as being a matter relating to
funding for
buildings owned by third parties
and purpose
and i hear that as being a matter of
partnership
rather than a matter of council
ownership
painting plaster
correct
infrastructure deals with those other
three pps the three p's that waste water
is to be utilized for
well
with the manager of governance and legal
sitting at the table he will ensure that
it is entered to the tracking report and
that that comes forward thank you i
suggest it's a popular pleasing puzzle
proven positively perplexing well
for sure
today your worship would you like to
bring this rebel back
meeting schedules your worship two very
simple recommendations this is something
we do every year happy to move them both
happy to second that your worship
we've been sick of the discussion
questions put it to the boat all in
favor say hi hi
yes
go to practice for land development and
the subdivision infrastructure bylaw
thank you your worship this reports for
information around a consultation that
will be undertaken
for a practice note or the code of
practice for land divers
land development and subdivision
infrastructure by law happy to take any
question
happy to move the two recommendations
you worship
happy to second though is your worship
moved and seconded that's one and two
infrastructure
vote all in favor say aye
aye it's carried i think
look i just got one
just
connections to three water reticulation
networks now when we do a bylaw
obviously we it's we're in charge at the
moment i think maybe but um
come the three waters uh being taken
away from us obviously
we would would this affect
our environment
there's a lot of water to go under the
bridge before you can determine that
finally
it must be the last council meeting of
the year
no
so obviously
i'm happy to make a comment on the three
waters integration if you'd like just
quickly
um i think just further to the chief
executive's comments um there's a lot to
work through in terms of the role that
council will continue to have in terms
of development and the role that new
water entities would potentially have in
terms of becoming
the asset controller for three waters so
we're definitely going to have to work
through how that
interaction happens and how we get
approval for them as to how to connect
to services etc moving forward
i mean just looking at the
worst case scenario you may have to be
communicating with christchurch for
example absolutely
or wellington
or switzerland
council o'clock
yes brian um at the meeting we went to
yesterday you heard um
some discussion about uh land use or
land development
in relation to going upwards as opposed
to cities expanding outwards
so is this um is this
code of practice going to look to that
we've had a submitter previously come to
council about the ability to go upwards
as opposed to go outwards there are
benefits for
infrastructure certainly three waters if
you do that
and we currently have some restrictions
around that so will this
open that up for some discussion
um this code of practice doesn't
specifically relate to that manner
counselor and the practice note is quite
specific relating to
those two issues of climate change
standards and the
subdivision
timing of infrastructure going in for
three waters
i mean it's very specific on this manner
but next year when there's a more
detailed discussion
around the
bylaw
that matter may come up at that point
because i noticed that in the background
here you mentioned the
new zealand standard land development
um code i guess or standard so that will
come at a later stage
this this code of practice already
exists and is based on that standard and
knows where the differences are
this report today deals purely with the
practice note around those two points
okay
uh you worship that item has been
moved and seconded and the motion has
been put already hasn't it
and so we're waiting for you to put this
motion in front of us okay
move on now then to the code of practice
for land
oh sorry
it's been moved and seconded i've now
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
temporary alcohol band
christmas at the races
i'm happy to move that your worship i'll
second that
look just making sure that that the
the under offenses and penalties that
that is not a typo that 20 that fine is
20 000 it just seems weird or 250 bucks
do you get a choice
i mean if you're the offender
i mean what it just sounds
massively huge the 20 000
for the offender and or 250 bucks
depending
on which part of the act he
it's deemed is that it just seems
just a huge
pretty um
gap is that correct that 20 000 and or
and or
right
20 250 bucks worst case scenario uh mr
morris is just coming to uh
act when you breach a by-law the fine is
up to twenty thousand dollars but that's
when you are prosecuted in court
uh for bylaw
um
alcohol bans
and including temporary bands you can
have an infringement fine which is the
250 that the police can issue which is
what they are most likely going to be
issuing
should there be a breach
so it is it isn't either or
but the police have the discretion to
decide which way they wish to proceed
and i would say 99.9 times out of 10
it's the infringement fine
but don't try them on
yeah thank you worship just a
clarification
on the uh date of christmas at the races
on saturday the 11th of december
i understand
within the boundary of the
ban area and racecourse road
there is a private
birthday party starting at 6 00 p.m for
an elderly citizen
and i just hope common sense prevails
because there will be a lot of elderly
people arriving for that party probably
5 p.m onwards and they will have food
and beverage with them i just hope that
the
authorities the security guards and
police are made aware of this and
beat them in
i think mr morris is coming to the table
too
there's always room
to allow for such things because it
recognizes that people who live along
there um need to
have their lives and not have their
lives um temporarily
affected by a ban
of alcohol the importance of the alcohol
ban however is that it actually does
protect those residents by and large um
because in times before we put the
temporary ban in place there would be a
lot of alcohol
consumed around the street and sort of a
pre-loading
issue
which
we all know does not tend to end well in
terms of behavior that's certainly the
evidence that's come through so that's
why but yes absolutely always room for
common sense to prevail if there is a
private function going on
uh in a residence along that
part of the road
it would be similar to the liquor ban in
the inner city where someone was taking
a bottle of wine to a byo they would be
allowed to do that and would not be
stopped or well they might be stopped no
question but
they probably wouldn't be prosecuted no
they'll be stopped and questioned and
then be sent on their way yeah she can
pop the top though
yes
yeah
so it's been moved and seconded
[Music]
we had a rather robust session with the
smears and chairs
and it doesn't appear that
uh i worship there is a male reporting
agenda and i'm just circulating the
um
thank you
thank you
foreign
very nice
thank you councillors my agenda's still
in the office so we'll start with the
mayor of magaya
just um
he's expressing his
his
support for the
quandary we're going through
and um
i think
this mayor was his grandfather was the
mayor when i was first elected and his
father your worship
his father
so
quite a personal relationship for those
who were fortunate enough to travel
before
david
19.
but um
just like to move that the report be
received
secondary wishes
and will be responding to
it's moved and seconded
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
and jewish is this late item of the
submissions to the emissions reduction
plan
submission on the admissions reduction
plan
he's speaking to that
um
so
as the chief executive mentioned the
reason that this is a light item for you
today is that it was discussed yesterday
at the regional hui that's many of you
didn't attend
um this is a joint submission that we
have supported and worked with
environment southland on
so um it's been provided here for your
information
it will be submitted by the due date
which is tomorrow um it does take into
account um the views of
councillor sopo and councillor munson
who are the leads for climate change
and it has had the input of a number of
officers from across council
so i think the consensus yesterday was
that it was a good um opportunity to put
forward a regional view and this
submission reflects the um discussion
that was held across the four councils
thank you questions counselor
um thank you your worship um i think
that this is an excellent um
submission to it and it's great to see
that we're working in conjunction with
environment southland but i would like
to talk um about the
uh
public transport sides of things um
at cheers meeting last week i spoke a
little bit about the free fears campaign
so it is a campaign
to provide
free fairs for tertiary students
those with community card
community card holders and um
oh goodness can't remember off the top
of my head
under 25s um
there's lots of people in our city that
um
lots of young people in our city that um
still find it difficult to access our
public transport um the this report here
um it does speak about the the fact that
a reduction in cost
um is a positive and that's really the
only way that we will get the uptake
required um for
any meeting any real
meaningful public transport outcomes
um it also talks about the cost of it
like a cost of electrification and
garnering a bit of support from our
central government but the free fears
campaign actually um drives for
obviously free fares paid for by central
government and gives it a bit of a
kickstart on that now there's some other
councils um across the country that have
already committed to supporting this and
the in as part of their um erp response
and erp submission
um
i would be really interested to know if
it's something that this council would
consider supporting or of course because
we actually um only have the contract
for public transport and invercargill or
we've been delegated authority to uh
provide public transport for
invercargill we don't have that the
actual mandate which sits with
environment southland that if we
encourage environment southland to take
a good look at it and support it
regionally rather than just this council
i think it would be a great thing for us
to get behind it's asking central
government to provide free fears for
those disadvantaged in our community
um
i've you can see um or that we have
statistics on the fact that you know
youth in the city and living in lower
socioeconomic areas
find it difficult to get into town or to
move around the city
in comparison to those that aren't so
that's my pitch and i would really hope
that my colleagues would support me on
it and
recommend that we recommend quickly i
suppose if this is going to have to go
forward tomorrow to environment
southland
that they consider supporting the free
fears campaign
thank you discussion questions counselor
yes i was at the meeting yesterday so
just a couple things around the
transport and the carbon farming as well
some degree of um
non-connectedness between us and the
other councils because we have different
environments so um
moving around this city is different
than moving between community hubs out
in the rural areas so there were
different needs being reflected there
um
the lack of e-charging for
e-m-e-e vehicles was raised
the recent development of e-bikes as
opposed to e-cars or just bikes was
thrown up and whether we have the right
infrastructure in place to allow e-bikes
which can travel up to 30 kilometers an
hour
around and in a city like area like ours
is a question for us to address some
later states so they were all they were
issues that raised and certainly from
the uh rural colleagues the issue of
carbon farming on what they see as food
producing land was also raised as well i
think they referred to categories four
and six agricultural sector land
and the benefits of carbon
um
was quite high for some for some
landowners to convert but the flip side
is you can't eat trees
and so um
quite quite a while but a discussion
from the other council species southern
district around that carbon farming
issue
but good paper going forward anyway your
worship i wonder if we could perhaps ask
the officer to explain
the reasoning for the comments and the
submission
okay so um within the submission there
is reference to the um free fair
campaign that councillor qriket refers
to
i'm certainly saying that um
councillor that the councils are
supportive of um
the goals of approving affordability
um
on the advice of the
roading manager who obviously is
responsible for public transport is the
reasoning for the wording within the
submission being the way that it is that
we propose that
the way to achieve modal shift is by a
lower rate of fairs for everyone rather
than purely focusing on free fares for
those groups so it's certainly a good
topic for discussion with council today
but the reasoning for that is that to
achieve modal shift requires getting
large numbers of people out of cars and
onto public transport and a significant
number of those groups are people who
are working who are not necessarily
students and they may have income a wide
range of income levels
so given
that the focus of
this emissions reduction plan is modal
shift and certainly equity within that
wider context
that um this would be why from an
officer level the recommendation
is certainly that it needs to be greater
affordability but this perhaps is an
option to consider
come to the cricket
thank you worship um absolutely
understand that and concur
the first
there's no reason in my mind why the two
things can't happen synonymously
if the government was to consider free
fares as a good start or reduced fears
is a good start for
um tertiary sorry i can confirm this now
tertiary students community care
services card holders and under 25s i
think that would be a good start the
secondary option would be that waka
kotahi could fund 50 of the fears um
minister what is on record is saying
local government should have skin in the
game uh which makes that 50 fear subsidy
more likely and i i understand that you
that you know not explicitly saying
the free fears campaign or a 50 subsidy
uh is what we're asking for um and that
the wording is a bit softer that you
know improving affordability but i think
having some
suggestions in there of tangible things
like the 50 subsidy or the free fears
campaign would be
a good step
steering point or a good platform to
benchmark off
your worship i wonder whether
um masuta is aware of the exact wording
that counselor cracker would like to see
in the submission there will be a
challenge in terms of that submission
being that alteration being accepted by
es and southland as well but do we have
clarity over the exact wording
would be useful to get
clarity
on what exactly
the difference would be that would be
useful
can i just the last sentence in that
paragraph says we propose the best way
to get modal shift
would be a flat rate fear of a dollar a
ride
flat rate fears such as a dollar a ride
or
waka kotahi 50 off fears or
free um free subsidy or free fares for
those
tertiary students community card
services or under 25s
so you worship that may be worthy of
more discussion at this table because
that is not the office's advice
in terms of the outcomes for emissions
reduction
and there's two things at play here
there's the emissions reduction plan
which three councils have endeavoured to
work together on
and there's a desire to support the
aotearoa collective for public transport
equity is the reference here and i'm not
sure whether that's exactly the right
name and the officer's advice as
rhiannon explained before was that that
won't make the contribution
that we are looking for in terms of
emissions reduction so i just want to be
bring councillors attention to that
before they start seeking changes to a
submission that's been worked on across
the board
councillor
thank you your worship
as one of the counsellors who
who
worked on this paper
um
i'm
very keen that we see those two things
as
separate
bearing in mind that this submission is
going away tomorrow
so it has to be away tomorrow and that i
have strong doubts that
um our partners
in
in
putting the submission together would
have the time to
um
make that wording change i've got no
objection to separately supporting what
counselor cricket is talking about i'm
just not sure that the place
to put the extra wording is in this
document
particularly considering the short time
frame
to get
quite that large an extension to the
wording when it's not
directly um
dealing with the emissions issue that
that the submission is about so i'm i'm
keen to support councillor cricket's
suggestion
um but but not necessarily as a change
to this particular submission
thank you worship um with that like i
can see the reasoning behind it this may
not be the world's most appropriate
place for it but i would like to pick up
the the topic because i think it really
does treat not only like random has seen
a modal shift but um there's a social
element to it as well and
connectivity for public transport so
perhaps the better place for that is
picking it up with the infrastructure
committee i did really just want to
highlight that that campaign is current
we are asking or lobbying central
government to provide lower fees or
subsidies as you'll know in the
erp the
public transport runs a significant loss
we need help basically
so anything
that improves those connectivity for
communities and you know
brings the bar down so people can
actually get back to socializing would
be excellent
i'll find another way to pick it up
thank you for entertaining
my wants your worship
all right all right
councillor clark yes thank you worship
my advocacy um i support alex's views
and
i guess i have to reflect that we got
this paper yesterday
and it has to be in tomorrow and you've
already seen the debate we've had
already and i think that's a
bit of an irony that we
are making a submission through the
central government
i we shouldn't lose the opportunity and
i don't see why as a city we can't put
an amendment or an attachment to this
document which doesn't require us to
negotiate with the others it just
declares that we have some additional
information that we'd like to attach
i think we should still attempt to do
that don't need to go back and
re-negotiate with the other two councils
or three councils
but we should just still signal it
because if we don't the opportunity
might be lost
and i think the issues are alex is right
it's a good issue so we should have to
look forward to the minister or the
ministry
thank you cancela ludlow thank you we
shall not support that approach because
i think
the issues that councillor crackit
raised
are peculiar to cargo city so they're
not
you know there's there's not a bus
system in in gaul or riverton or
anywhere else so yeah
oh bluff
used to be a great one
um
i always said at the front
um so i i think an additional
brief submission or or note
with an emphatical perspective would be
a good
option
who would you have in mind for drawing
up this proposal really
ppp support group
your worship
there is an issue that we're at 4 30 and
there is an all-day commitment tomorrow
um
i think councillor crackit's point is
one that isn't part of the emissions
reduction plan for invercargill that's
what
mr pearson was saying
support for the
atroa collective may be better addressed
elsewhere
um
but
it's been referenced in here in a small
way
you worship i just wanted to make the
point that
the submission is to the emissions
reduction plan
a suggestion of putting in that
particular issue in an expanded form
from invicable city council
is not appropriately part of a response
to the emissions reduction plan
it is an appropriate response to make
elsewhere and i would suggest something
that will certainly be taken for further
by local government new zealand or that
we may ourselves as a council want to
discuss taking further to local
government new zealanders policy etc but
my concern with asking our staff to take
the time to write another paper at very
short notice
even as an attachment is that
this is a submission on the emissions
reduction plan and we
don't want
to add an extra page that is not until
entirely relevant
to what the submission is actually about
um thank you your worship i have
listened um of course and heard um
and i that makes absolute logical sense
if we are to put something together to
uh
make or you know to advocate for the
advocacy was best spent in the right
place
so um
i will turn my mind on on how to do that
and
bring something back
thank you
further discussion questions put it to
the boat all in favor say aye aye
did we have a mover for that item a
mover and a seconder
i don't
[Music]
agenda
excluded from the following parts of
proceedings of this meeting
with the exception of external
appointees mr jeff graham
mr lindsey mckenzie
which
hi
you